[Music]
welcome guys to
today's lecture on the master's choice
today for today's lecture i prepared
uh two games i would like to talk about
and they are
based uh i mean they're from u.s
championships that
have been held we
finished week ago right so the games i
prepared are
my game versus jeffrey young and the
other game observer jeffrey actually
against
wesley saw and both had one
thing in common that bob were playing
there one very sharp opening
which was fetching operations in the
sicilian
his opening is very interesting of
course it's one of the
most too popular or well well-studied
openings in sicily in general in chinese
but
specifically specifically in sicily
along with neidorf
so i think
in general this opening positions are
extremely complicated
both sides are not backing out both
sides
play as active and dynamic chess as
possible
and this leads to very interesting
positions so
i wanted to bring it up today and i will
show
as i said two games uh from which from
us championship is when
this opening happened and we'll see how
uh
[Music]
what what happened in both games
actually both games white won
but this doesn't matter because the
games the blackheads is on chances
anyway
so let's just jump into it and talk
about
[Music]
the games so uh i'm not sure whether i
want to have it from vice president
probably from now from black's
perspective because i play this game
with black is my game against jeffrey
jung
so e4 c5 knight the three knight c6 d4
take stakes knight f6 knight c3 e5
i should also say that this pop this
opening has always been very popular but
lately
uh has been you know even more popular
because of
the games of magnus carlsen who used it
against fabian caruana in
world championship match in 2018
and also after that magnus was playing
very often
this was sicilians so
thanks to games of world champion
there have been tremendous jump in
theory and knowledge in this opening
so uh therefore even though i haven't
played it
before i also began you know sort of
employing this opening of myself as
black
with black pieces so knight b5 d6 uh
bishop g5
other possibility is knight d5 here
which is what sound 7 played against me
in the first round of us championships
and also it is it is actually the line
that uh
fabian one was playing his minus in
world championship match
it is also very interesting different
type of positions
and i'm not going to talk about my game
against sam7 today
however i think in general black is
doing quite well there too
so bishop g5 happened in my game against
jeffrey a6
knight a3 b5 knight sorry bishop to xf6
other possibilities knight d5 which is
what happened in
wesley wesley's game against jeffrey
bishop takes f6 however is
more is it's more concrete it's
much sharper i think than knight d5 95
is considered a little bit positional
approach for instance after bishop b7
bishop f6 takes
and c3 or c4 are both positional
options for white rather calm we're
trying to prove the string of the d5
knight however bishop takes f6
gf knight d5 of course queen f6 runs
into 95 with tempe and this is not
something that
white uh mr black enjoys so gtx f6
right now the phrase b4 obviously so
white has got knight d5 and black plays
f5
other possibilities of course play
bishop g7 which is what magnus played
uh however i've i found five uh
as you know compiling choice personally
so i like it
and and here there have been lots of
theory there have been all games of
carrick aspara where
against i think alexis shira were alex
escher was playing bishop takes b5
sacrificing a piece
however the current stereo theory is
that black is doing well there and
at best what i can hope for is a
perpetual check or some
europe or some draw other draw uh
so those lines are built like bishop to
b5 are not really dangerous
particularly i think because rook a4
right now is very strong move the ringer
with the rook
and putting suppression on the e4 pawn
after knight c7 king d7 black
is generally considered as be doing
quite well
uh so um the
the modern theory how it develops uh has
developed lately
sort of is like a revolving around
bishop move bishop d3
and bishop d3 can happen in many many
options uh first of all
c3 bishop g7 says what jeffrey played
now bishop d3
is it one possibility and second
possibility is bishop d3 immediately
bishop e6 and short castle i think i'm
mistaken
and both options are very interesting
and
i think in both white can so has some
chances to for an advantage however
objectively black with correct players
should be doing
okay uh i would like to discuss what
jeffrey will play against me because
after all if he played he had to have
something prepared and
he had to slide his opening so c3 bishop
g7
bishop d3 bishop b6 and now jeffrey
played queen h5 which is
not as common as uh other moves i think
uh there are a few years ago
like maybe five maybe ten i don't know
i'm not sure
exactly when was it 95 was considered as
extremely dangerous
and after this bishop takes b5 uh
you know uh bishop d7 i think is the the
line
like the five and there is basically uh
white has basically two three pawns for
a piece
and the very good compensation for the
forest piece especially with this such
powerful knight on d5
those spawns on the queen side are
likely to be you know marching forward
uh also black's king is a little bit
dangerous and because it's exposed
and it's been considered as a
good try for white to play uh for a win
however um modern you know theory
claims that black is also doing quite
well here however the position is
extremely complicated uh
i don't want to dive into specific
variations because it's just
so much to study here and it's been
studied for
you know years for
and by grammar and grammar masters and
so on
and uh studying just memorizing you know
like theory discussing right now
it's not my point it's not not what i
want to do i would like i
would rather discuss what happened my
game and
in general ideas that happens in this
opening so
uh queen h5 is what jeffrey played and i
remember here there was one very
interesting
approach here by black it's not the only
approach but i found it as a very
interesting one
short castle it takes f5 bishop takes d5
f6
and right now it seems like white is
getting black is getting mated on h7 but
while come back and play e4
but f2 is g7 and now rook e8
this is all theory
black kings seemingly is exposed but on
the other hand is well guarded by this
white pawn on g7 of course
if uh black would take this um
this pawn uh queen d5 would follow and
the black
black actually is losing a piece however
uh after rookie eight
uh the spawn g7 actually shielding a
black kink from any checks and so on uh
so black king is actually pretty safe
even though it seems like it's exposed
so bishop b2 is the main move right now
and in this position black has basically
two possibilities they're knight d5 or
rook e5
rocky five is con i think is the most
popular one
uh and there have been main games i
think
uh uh liam laguang played uh
rookie five in one of his games and he
won it's also
it's a decent option for black however
personally when i was analyzing this on
my own i found 95 as
was pretty strong and i didn't find any
problems here for black also it's pretty
logical to just place the knight in the
center
where it can go many directions can go
maybe to f3 because there is some
pressure on the e-file
or maybe it also supports bishop c4
ideas
where and then maybe trying to get with
knight to d3 it
seems it seemed very logical approached
by us black for me here
uh so after castle queen f6 this is
basically the critical position right
now the white has big choice
and um jeffrey played pretty quickly
move knight c2 and this is the move that
i had in on
that that i didn't analyze in the past i
but i like something very similar
also i did i have to say that i didn't
expect jeffrey to play this line so i
didn't quite remember everything here
so uh i saw the moon knight c2
somewhere but no it wasn't the exact
position that i
had in mind when uh that i sort of
i saw this move by different position
what i'm trying to say is that i saw
after i after the game i analyzed this a
little bit more and i had by some reason
queen h3 as the main move
and idea is that after rp8
knight c2 the point of queen h3 is
simply to run away from all kind of
tactics
involving knight f3 and
knight c2 however i buy some reason i
dismissed
because i uh presumed or something
that there is some tactics involving
knight f3 but during the game it wasn't
so clear to me on what i remember though
that there are ideas of bishop c4
and bishop c4 is the move that basically
traces a pair of bishops simplifies the
question a little bit
and i want to leave my knight on d3 at
some point as i said earlier
but i wasn't sure whether this position
is partly it is
this is particularly great and i didn't
decide to go for it especially that
alternative
was extremely tempting but just to show
quickly what can happen
bishop c4 bc knight d3 i think the black
is doing quite well after
queen g6 even though white is with x
with an extra pawn pawn g7 is going to
fall anyway at some point
and black can play princess rupe8 soon
maybe some ideas with knight d3 in the
future
considering of course the policy for uh
will be defended
night basically i don't think black has
too much of
too many reasons to worry here i think
black is doing quite
quite okay but i had an alternative
which was
very tempting i spent lots of time
calculating it
which was move knight f3 and neither
three
mo the move knight of three is the most
critical move and
it's by far um the most challenging
for uh for white and i think jeffrey
missed it but um because
why i'm saying him i'm thinking that he
missed it because after i was free he
started thinking
for a really really long time
and the the point is that after
let's say g takes f3 i go simply rookie
5 and suddenly his queen is trapped
if he's doing his queen because after
queen h3 i go bishop b6
chasing uh his queen away
harassing his queen i mean and finally
if the queen goes to the g file
somewhere we can uncomplete rule g5 and
i simply
win uh win the queen so neither so
knight of three i was really excited to
play
obviously but i was i couldn't evaluate
in the end was happening
uh because he took that bishop is what i
was thinking is the best move of course
rookie 5 has to be played
right now there are two moves there
queen g4 or queen h3
and queen h3 is obviously correct
queen g4 is incorrect
because first of all it runs into rook
g5 possibilities so it goes under 10 ps
in all possible all random lines rogue
g5 is possible so basically
it has to be dismissed immediately
because gold gives additional options
for black friends i can play right now
maybe
which if i'm going to play it take on
the f3 and play the emperor with g5
uh and if i put my rook on
the g file uh pawn g2 will be also under
attack so
it gives some additional tempest to
black's attack and so this should be
dismissed however queen h3 was my main
uh it was the main thing i was
calculating it takes f3
and right now knight e3 and basically
here in the i was when i was calculating
the three i was thinking about those
lines
and the only move i was considering here
was the
move i played here ftx g2 and this is
this is a good move
uh but there is but it's not necessary
move
as it appears uh what's going on here
basically white tries to play knight g4
right and this is uh seemingly one of
them
also um on top of knight g4 with the
fork there's also move like rook d1 root
d4 so they're basically two ideas that
dwight has
and um what
what tries to accomplish is to place
everything on the dark squares
neutralize my play on the light squares
and
proved that knight is stronger than the
bishop in the let's say middle game and
and or maybe in some end games trading
queens is definitely one of the good
options for
uh for white because white has bare pawn
structure let's say if we
take off the the queens of the board
let's say in such following line
apart from the fighter white has extra
pawn this
so yeah let's say extra pawn pawn on d6
right now is a weakness
y can play rook d1 rook d4 or something
and then double on the default
on dark squares white has full control
on top of the extra pawn so what should
be
should be winning here i
as black i cannot trade queens if i
trade queen it means
that i'm much worse here so i try to
basically play as
dynamic just as i could uh however i
made a mistake
um later on so here i play gta ftx g2
and this is a good move as i said but
there is some there's alternative which
is
by far not not not worse than this
and actually from practical standpoint i
think it's even better
the point is to play uh the best movies
practical choice
uh the best practical choice we need to
play simply rook 88
idea what is the idea the rook is
zeruk is not participating in the game
bring it in as
simple as that if knight takes d5
rook takes d5 queen takes f3 if he just
collects the pawn i can
play right now rookie two with such
active rooks there are no any issues
here for me
at all uh black is doing completely okay
rook d2 is coming
i can have rook take the gssg sample any
moment and
black is doing simply great here uh so
uh knight if some sort of like worry
here
is always knight g4 but suddenly queen
knight g4 doesn't work tactically
i can play queen e6 only move but it's
sufficient and
knight takes e5 suddenly i can play ftag
g2 this move of course i didn't see
um and suddenly black is winning or like
at least it's much better
so the point is that after queen e6 for
instance i take you first
uh with check group has to orkin has to
take and after this
uh the in this endgame black is simply
better because pawn only to
uh i mean first of all there's rook g6
checkmate actually king of one is
way more accurate just be more precise
right now rook takes e6 and the thing is
that
in this end game blog is simply better
uh
probably yeah plug simply better i will
not say black is winning because they're
probably a long way
but uh definitely black has very good
chances to win this
because of dynamics it's unclear where
design goes first
and i can take this pawn g7 any moment
uh black is doing simply great
so in this position rook e8 was very
let's say
difficult move to play because like you
normally from
normally you want to just you know
points on the free just take further in
g2 there's nothing wrong with this
seemingly right
so i took that's what i was thinking it
should be fine
of course he never can take on g2
because of g5 however we
achieve right now very very strange
position because
he has pawn on g7 i have pawn on g2 and
the question is what how to assess this
like who is better here
and posit the the answer is the position
is pretty much equal
after only but i have to play one
specific move and
which of course i saw but i saw also
alternative
um essentially i saw two possible moves
here for white sorry for black
and the
during the game it seemed like a coin
flip which one is stronger
and i unfortunately i chose wrong and
yeah so pretty much after bishop b6 is
what i did
queen g3 my idea was to simply cover g4
square in any case
and just
you know play a play is solid you know
pistol misses well
was well placed it is kind of be
attacked from here
seems like very solid move however
bishop f3 it was
alternative which is ice what i saw but
i was much
stronger and this was the best move uh
for black
but i didn't like it because of rook d4
and let's say rookie 8 or something with
queen g3 this was i was worried about
because right now if he can play luke 4
he will kick my bishop out
and whenever i retrieve the bishop from
f3
he'll have some ideas of knight g4 and
so on so this is what i was
worried about but like i didn't realize
if i retrieve my bishop
let's say to c6 or somewhere on this
diagonal my pawns on g2 still
defend it so he cannot remove his knight
from me free because he will get
checkmated with ruby one
so that's the big uh that's the big
difference right now between
you know between those moves right now
uh he cannot take
the g2 pawn and the b56 is very active
on this diagonal
but bishop on my rooks are connected
knight g4 is never a fret
suddenly dynamically uh black is doing
quite well
however and this was correct as decided
i played bishop b6 and after
queen g3 we achieved similar position
but positions
right now way different and i think from
practical point of view it is extremely
difficult to
play this position with black and i
couldn't find a move to be honest
and like i lost pretty quickly this but
uh
you know anyway position was extremely
difficult already at least from
practical point of view
of course i could basically maybe trade
take here trade queens but like as i
said earlier trading queens
it means uh accepting the fact that
i'm you know simply worse here in this
position
like pawn g2 will fall at some point so
i will likely be moved with uh you know
down the pawn with the position down the
pawn and this is certainly something not
something i
enjoyed so i tried to create some
contour i didn't want to trade queen so
i tried to play
h5 value of h4 but this is simply uh
buried by rook d4 king h7
whether rook j rook g7 tried to somehow
uh
attack on the king side but of course it
doesn't work group d1
there are also other moves that win but
this is one of the
nicest let's say or simplest rg8 f4
right now
root ac5 and f5 and
suddenly my bishop that i thought is
pretty safely located on e6
is actually not so safe because under
runs onto this f405 idea
and white simply wins after an bishop
takes a 59 d5
the point is that after let's say
quintex g7 there's queen d6
and there is a problem for i'll just put
on the board
uh queen d6 and there is a knife six on
the c5 is hanging it's
just completely winning for for white so
i decided to play queen h6 trying to
sort of hold it together uh you know my
pawn on h6
try not try not to give him knight f6
but after queen f2 i have no
uh good way to defend his bishop
and i decide to decide to give the
exchange for instance with bishop e6
he comes with knight knight f6 so also
doesn't work
so i play bishop the the rook takes d5
this this route h7 i tried to hold it
but of course
absolutely lost again his king is very
safe behind the
the my pawn my own pawn on g2 and there
is nothing pretty much i can do here
okay six he just collected one pawn
maybe his technique would have been a
little bit more
uh let's say accurate but he never let
me go in for a second here so
he jeffrey converted pretty convincingly
so yeah uh
this is how the game ended
rudy 40 h4 and this is hero this is
where i resigned
uh it was great game by jeffrey even
though this knight c2 idea was
maybe um as sound as
because of this night of free
possibility but like then i had to be
super accurate and i
made some mistakes unfortunately i lost
so this is the game
for the first game i on the show and
second game i want to show today on this
vishnikov
was the actually critical game for us
championships title
because it was between two uh players
who
were co-leading i think at this point
before the around
10 or roughly around 9. it was between
jeffrey uh with black and wesley saw
with with white pieces so uh
the game um i will actually put it
right now from wise perspective so the
game followed with e4 c4 c5
nikov bishop g5 a6 knight a3 b5 knight
d5 mission b7
uh jeffrey chose bishop f6 wesley chose
95
bishop f6 c3 uh bishop g5 knight c2
rubio this is all well-known theory
um modern trend i think daniel lubov
played it like
first time also i saw jeffrey playing
this against
leonardo dominguez uh in saint louis
wrapping blitz
so um definitely jeffrey
prepared some had some you know ideas
here
wesley played move a3 which is a little
bit
i don't know how to put it but like i
thought it's a little bit mysterious
move
like before it's not really a threat
still so but maybe it's kind of like
waiting move like i always have kind of
like
issues understanding why why free like
a4
is logical because you change the pawn
structure right but a3
seems like it's sort of waste of time
but maybe not really because all the
other worldwide is doing
anyway this is how the modern theory
develops sometimes you know one move
one quiet move and suddenly open maybe
has
no no good response to this this is not
if the case here i think but anyway a
free list to very
you know interesting and playable
positions too so short castle played
jeffrey and
h west's idea was to play h4 uh of
course
this one one of the typical ideas is
freshnikov you cannot take because of
queen h5
after bishop h6 uh the idea is to play
g4
so wesley tries to play quickly g5 and
win this bishop or if or in case of f6
the king side will be
pretty much you know weak so
the best move right now is to play
bishop f4
and queen f3 i assume that wesley played
all those moves pretty quickly
here we go to this point and uh here
sorry the wesley played this
i said wesley right so i think we are
whether the west you play all those
moves correctly uh
quickly and um i'm not sure if jeff was
thinking or not
but here in this position i think
jeffrey made a mistake
because as i said
you know initially especially was such
an opening that
you know very dynamic play very active
and concrete play is
pretty much required you cannot just you
know play passively or
you know make some you know lousy moves
like for instance uh i know king aj for
instance here like you'll be just a
waste of time also the forest hanging
so you need to sort of some find a way
to react to this
either find counter play or defend it
somehow so
um as i said fashion was very dynamic
opening
as is entire sicilian to be honest so
um i what i analyzed after the you know
after this game ended and like on my own
i think that a5 right now was one of the
very interesting ways to approach this
position as black
it's all again all about dynamics right
now if knight takes a four seemingly
white wins the pawn right
take stakes what could be why would be
so great for black
and the thing is that black simply plays
before
thanks to those pawns on g4h4 white king
has no really good
way to uh there's no really good
square good good or good place for a
white king here while if what goes
for castle you know those pawns are you
know exposed
exposing the king's side so the king
will not be super safe on the king side
too
quick of course is out of question and
center you know
king never is or rarely is safe in the
center
so suddenly with this before white
jeffrey would open the queen they keep
queen side and
potentially create some weaknesses so i
thought that this
this was correct play here here by uh by
black after c4 for instance analyze b3
knight d3
and queen b6 and the idea is of course
uh
to you know just develop all the pieces
as quickly as possible
maybe queen d4 could be afraid maybe
queen b4 could be a threat
and very dynamically put some pressure
on
on white kink which is still in the
center and it's not clear where is it
going because let's say bishop e2 their
queen before
can follow which is not easy to face as
well
i thought rook d1 but then queen before
king e2 95 and
it seems like black has great
compensation here
for instance f3 and rook a8 while they
are k2 it feels like
uh it doesn't feel like
white has any advantage here if anyone
has some
initiative it is black so uh
and the difference the reason for this
is basically the difference in king
safety
black's king is super safe white's king
you know is in the center and
also white pieces are not well developed
like bishop is still on f1 kirk is on h1
king is only two looks like sort of
maybe it's bad reference but like it
looks like some sort of king's gambit
uh where of course white's king is in
the center
right so here is the similar thing even
though white has extra pawn white has
a very exposed king
so this is kind of typical play that you
can expect you know in um
in fashion if you sacrifice a pawn for
initiative
so a5 was basically the way to go here
for black
however jeffrey play move bishop b7
which is the move that i don't really
like um you know you played already rook
b8
try to utilize it with my thing or if
you want to play
with this bishop somewhere played maybe
onto e6 uh
i don't know uh seems like bishop b7
doesn't quite belong there at least to
me
uh and but the bishop b7 after bishop b7
uh
it was wesley's turn and he also made a
mistake i guess you know first of all
in general in this game there were lots
of mistakes from both sides
and i would find two explanations for
this first of all
the time control actually three three
reasons the time control in rapid chess
unlike in classical chess uh you know
the
chance of inaccuracies or mistakes is
much higher than in
um you know longer time controls
and the another thing is that
uh position itself is in with this
opening is very complicated
and finally the stake the you know they
were playing for the first place
so um winner takes it all pretty much
right
so uh here probably also nerfs
have been playing some role so bishop b7
uh played jeffrey and
wesley play moved g5 and actually after
i think after g5 black would be
new could be better actually um
what what's going on uh the idea of
bishop b7 is to
basically in case of knight f4 uh play
queen f6
and then why do black will recapture
the pawn the sorry the piece on f4 and
have this bishop m7 hitting on the
center
it's but after 93 let's say queen f4
bishop g2
is what analyzed of course if he takes
the f4 the knight d5 would follow
and this should be better for white
because white wins the pawn and black
doesn't have enough compensation
uh you know a4 a5 before us earlier is
pretty much too slow and
here sorry a knight f4 queen f6
an id3 if queen f4 bishop g2 i think
that in this end game
uh white is slightly better
because of the purple structure and
this backward d6 pawn that
will be under attack after let's say
some rook d1 moves 95
maybe doubling on the d file all those
moves all those ideas
white have and white has and black will
be forced to be
on the defensive side here and another
possibility is to prepare
prepare all of it if we remove bishop g2
because i'm not sure how black is going
to defend that f4
for bishop uh like you know the ponder
uh
anyway just to sum it up i'm not sure
what bishop b7 was bringing here
but uh yeah
because of yeah those lines that i said
i think what is better
ways better uh however it was to play g5
and suddenly that bishop b7 idea could
have been justified
right now if jeffrey played move knight
a5
you know it's pretty pretty natural move
actually because uh
your blue play bishop be7 first then you
want to open this bishop
uh this diagonal for this bishop and put
some pressure on
the center especially on design on d5
the idea is for instance to maybe play
knight b3 knight c5
one day one idea second idea is to
eliminate the
knight from d5 and basically secure his
bishop on the f4
and this white and if white sorry black
manages to accomplish that
i think black would be only better here
so
it seems natural to take it take the
pawn
but after this bishop before suddenly
works
white's king is exposed in the center so
you cannot just
freely take this pawn on e4 just to show
quickly
you cannot take because r8 uh wins the
queen right
so um you cannot take the pawn and let's
say if you go for
a long castle suddenly f5
becomes very interesting choice by black
and position gets extremely complicated
but if anyone's taking any risk right
now i think it's it is white
for instance after queen f4 f takes e4
their ideas of e3 their ideas of rook
f3.f2 is the weak pawn as well
i've probably of correct play black
sorry white can sort of hold it
but uh it is extremely dangerous for
instance
queen takes d6 would already lose the
game after knight b freak in b2 king b1
takes takes
and e3 simply wins the game on the spot
um yeah like i i don't see them one of
two is falling the pawn the e pawns
you know very like very likely will just
be promoted to the queen
uh also we're gonna try saying so we
cannot take only free as well
so um knight a5 would be
would basically shift the initiative
towards
towards black and white and i think
white would be
pretty much in trouble at least from
practical point of view
however jeffrey played rook e8 and i
don't like this move because
again it's kind of passive like if you
play this opening you need to play very
very active right
and the same thing happened in my
previous game in jeffrey because i had
two moves bishop f3 bishop e6
and i chose the more passive more solid
one instead of bishop of three which is
more
aggressive more forward right and
the same thing happens here rookie 8 is
kind of like more passive move
knight a5 a value of taking bishop d5
and then
you know playing maybe for f5 and so on
seems very very strong
because it's more dynamic and more
aggressive in the game happen the right
one takes a four it takes the four
and i think after long castle uh wesley
is doing great again
um he has great position uh right now
pawn on four is hanging pawn on d6 also
is potentially weak
however there are certain tactical ideas
involving this on this
uh i mean involving this bishop and rook
on this diagonal
let's say pawn on e4 is pretty weak
right so when
we can somehow remove this knight from
there tactically uh pawn only four will
be hanging
will fall and with it we're gonna be
under attack too
so uh right now jeffrey probably says
that if he doesn't do
right now if something very concrete or
denied or dynamic
he'll just lose the pawn and he don't
have any compensation for this
therefore he was looking for drastic
measures and
he found one with which was moved to
play b4
and this move uh
is very sharp that's for sure and it
creates
lots of pressure on like you know more
like tension on the
king sorry queen side and the center too
so atex before knight takes before
obviously you have to remove the knight
to access the e4 pawn
and right now uh jeff sorry wesley had
two
possibilities either take the knight on
before or take the pawn on b4
nothing else you have to take the knight
the question is with what
and as i said most likely because of the
nerves and kind of like the stake of the
tournament or also
the rapid time control he wanted to make
quick decision
and maybe you know in such position you
have simply have to calculate
and calculate very accurately because
position is pretty much crazy if you
make one mistaking calculation
the game could be over and this is
exactly what could have happened
actually in this game
uh so right now jeffrey
sorry wesley played knight x before and
this was a mistake
uh the best move was to play that the
pawn on
before after bishop takes e4 plays
simply queen h3
the point is that white doesn't have to
be worried about opening a c file
because bishop d3 is coming next
and if bishop is coming d3 to d3 next it
secures
everything on the queen side and the
game is uh
the blacks initiative will pretty much
evaporate very soon
for instance if a bishop takes c2 you
try and prevent bishop takes d3
blah blah blah rook takes b4 but then
just for instance queen c3
securing on b2 i if i secure on b2 i
will be fine
queen c1 and bishop c4 is coming
i don't see any follow-up to black's
initiative right now i think what's
simply winning
so um if queen c7 on the other hand
y can play this time bishop d3 and after
bishop takes h1 rook takes h1
i don't see really uh what black can do
okay rotate b4 still can be played
obviously but for h5
y can simply ignore black's activity
which
is nearly gone
and pretty much is is not existent
anymore
uh pawn uh and white simply continues to
attack on the
king side by once played g6 and to
destroy uh
black's king and
same time leaving our white king
pre-save on the on c1
or some in general on the queen side
pretty much black has no manpower sort
of to continue the initiative here while
white has potential of creating you know
some very strong attack on the king side
so if this happened i think jeff sorry
wesley would have had
big advantage however
such i you know deciding in such
position after netex before
which move is correct requires
lots of you know caution and uh
[Music]
i don't know how to put it but very
very uh strong nerves to basically
with to be cold-blooded sort of and
super calm and play syntax before in
such positions it's very difficult so
knight
b4 is more human obviously however
bishop takes e4
after bishop takes e4 uh right now jo
wesley played again a mistake he played
quintex f4 which is again the most let's
say human move
um
or maybe not the most human move but
like you know the kind of logical move
because
uh you want to eliminate you you can
take the pawn what could be
wrong with that what could be wrong with
the taking uh taking the pawn right
and uh seemingly also queen goes to the
dark square
so stabilizing the let's say a little
bit the center
or like you know um they could not go
under any attack
and things like that so
we'll see what happened after queen day
what could have happened after queen of
four but
queen h3 was only move and after rook
takes b4 cdxb4
queen c8 very strong move uh idea is to
basically
uh you know queen c8 let's say rook c8
and the rook on h1 falls
which takes each one and i think in this
end game black black should uh
black should be doing quite okay should
we eventually draw
however there is move queen c3 it's just
very difficult move to play obviously
after bishop h1 uh there is there are
several options for white
i think that the phrases bishop h3 uh
i know queen c6 is sorry queen b7 rook
d6
bishop f3 this position is extremely
difficult to play for with both colors
both king white king is exposed but so
is black king
even though it seems like it's sheltered
by its own pawns but
so there are certain background issues
so position is you know pretty much
difficult to play with both colors
i think it's still that wide it's
slightly better
but uh not more than that um
while definitely it's a very complicated
position and anything can happen
technically
so uh this was correct way to play buzz
white instead
jeff wesley played queen takes the four
and right now uh jeffrey missed the
golden opportunity to win the game
nearly on the spot
because he played move rock takes before
which is
seemingly very natural because after c
takes before uh queens c7 is
mating attack and rook b4 therefore
seemingly is the most natural move to
play however you play queen a5
you also on top of rook takes before you
want to play queen a1 and queen takes b2
and
attack the white king in this way again
this opening
involves lots of dynamic and concrete
play
and
you need to basically be ready for such
uh
such moves uh or you know fighting you
know
solving such moves and it's not easy for
anyone to play
like this so queen e5 suddenly was
i need to fix your microphone oh okay
you turn it off
all right there we go
all right uh okay sorry about that
anyway uh queen a5 was
basically very powerful option here for
jeffrey
unfortunately he for him he missed it
the point is that right now queen a1
queen b2 is just
very very strong uh threat and nearly
irresistible
if knight c2 queen a2 is like
i don't see move technically for for a
while because queen b2 just follows
uh if bishop d3
bishop takes h1 right now if rook takes
h1 queen a1
and if king goes queen takes h1 and
bishop b1 then come under comes to e2 so
suddenly black is in
drive driver's seat and
white king is near pretty much getting
mated right now
so i thought the three was the only
tribe but after bishop g2 actually black
has extra exchange
and uh not only there is extra exchange
but
it is a black west initiative on on on
white against white's king
for instance bishop c bishop c4 just
king h8 we can just ignore this f7 pawn
the most important
our own our own king safety too h5 and
the
bishop h3 are analyzed if h6 bishop f5
bring the bishop to the correct diagonal
i different in queen a1 again
after hg both king h7 both king hg7 i
mean and king g8 win
king jada for like it's a little bit
more simple because it doesn't even
allow queen d4 check
so uh black would be just winning here
there is no way that the white could uh
create any danger to black king right
now
so yeah queen a5 would
pretty much actually win the game i
don't see actually the defense right now
for
uh for white because um
what to do like queenie one suddenly is
a big threat and it's not easy to defend
also routes before
is still in the air you can play this
you know very very soon
so yeah quintex a5 queen a5 would be
just be crushing probably however uh
you know of course it's not an easy move
to play and to understand it especially
when you see such tempting move like
bishop
like grouptex before and you know the as
i said the
main reason of all those mistakes in
like in general in rapid chat is the
time control it's not
people can play chess it's just because
the rush decisions sometimes lead to
incorrect decisions and uh with rapid
chess
uh is this this is how it is basically
uh also if i if i played uh if i had
this position
previous my previous game against
jeffrey uh that i showed
and i have to decide bishop between
bishop f3 and bishop e6
also would be different let's say
classical game i would have higher
chance of
making of understanding was really going
on
rather than simply guessing
because for me it was a coin flip i
didn't want to spend too much time i
just wanted to make a move and
because both moves seemed equal to me
and they were not
so there's probably probably the time
control and like the pressure
on making the move is the source of
mistakes here
so uh rook takes before is what jeffrey
plays very logical move but suddenly
after bishop d3
there is no clear follow-up what to do
here with with black
and the position right now is just equal
and the
jeffrey played right now bishop takes h1
and this is
again a little bit inaccurate it's no
natural but also a little bit inaccurate
in my opinion what was correct is to
play rook a4 and
the point is just just
let's say from kind of like perspective
human perspective
why there is no reason to because what
bishop h1 accomplishes
is to trade this rook for this rook
and rook on before is very active rook
on h1 doesn't have
anything yet so there is makes little
sense to trade the active rook for a
very passive rook
so therefore i think rogue a4 was
stronger
but black is what's obviously
financially replicated say here
rook a1 king d2 take take bishop takes
the freak into his d3
and uh king on the 3 is a little bit
exposed true but there is no way to get
to these kings let's say after rookie 6
black would be just possibly just equal
i think
uh yeah but in this position
jeffrey looked bishop xh once and
suddenly after right now queen takes
before
bishop a free queen the rogue d2
suddenly i think white is slightly
better
because right now white has sorry black
has weaknesses pawn on a6 and pawn and
d6
pawns h4 g5 restrict black skin
and it is not easy for black to
you know to solve let's say sometimes
background issues because you never want
to play move like g6 because it weakens
all the dark squares around your king
and moves like h6 all will always allow
gtx h6 which destroys the king
uh king's you know defensive um
king's pawn defense um so
suddenly i think what started better
objectively according to engines
obviously black is doing quite okay
still but let's say on human from human
point of view
of look just what is why is everything
protected
if i play let's say b freak in b2 my
king also i wouldn't have any issues on
the background as
well i can play say bishop c2 then
attack this d6 pawn and
maybe challenges if the bishop from a
free somehow
it seems like white has lots of ideas
and black is has to be general on the
defensive side
so jeffrey right now probably realized
that and he played move d5
trying to maybe play d4 or something or
something i have no idea
uh or maybe just to just to defend this
deep on
like um pre seems pretty pretty logical
on the other hand i think that rookie
one and g6 would be
uh quite okay still for black trying to
first of all solve the background issue
and try to hope that you know making
uh the whole dark source around the king
will not be
too uh too problematic
because um of the contraband white black
tries to
create on white's king still i think
white
started better because of move like for
instance b3 and king b2 bishop c2 was
just
the same plan as i said earlier however
uh
bishop 6 also is possible but
unnecessary for now i think
i'll be freaking b2 bishop c2 uh
uh would be much let's say more solid
the thing is
attribution takes a6 let's say d5 i
don't know queen c5 or something bishop
before
the king white king is constantly under
some pressure yes you can play
maybe move like bishop d3 but if we try
to
those bishops there will be always some
checks on on the on this king and black
will have
some hopes to create you know counter
play and against white's king
therefore uh i think if white can manage
at first to hide the king first
be freaking b2 on the dark squares uh
play bishop c2 but why we slightly
better here
jeffrey played d5 which is also you know
quite logical
and uh again b3 and the idea kim b2
was the way to go here for white with
will advantage
uh wesley was greedy
he took out the pawn on e6 there's also
nothing wrong with that
apart from the fact that it's not uh the
the mood that keeps the advantage or
gives the advantage
uh first thing to understand here is
king of the save
the safety of the king and
with the castle on opposite sides
king safety is even more of a concern
that or like priority that you know
player has to pay attention to
uh so be free can be two at first and
then think about some
some other stuff because after bishop a6
uh
it you know suddenly you know first of
all i can play just rookie one what
do i said earlier and then say g6 and a
similar position would
what we discussed earlier actually i
think it's the same one
so
as discussed earlier black has some
compensation here
on top of that black has a number of
other possibilities for instance
h6 and this is of jeffrey played
basically right now jeffrey undermines
the pawn structure
and because respond bishop on a6 is
misplaced
uh there are a certain drawing
or like you know equalizing ideas for
black for instance after gtx h6
the point is to play rook e4 with bishop
on d3 was never possible right
bishop on a6 suddenly is misplaced and
there is such idea
such idea exists right now so the point
is
and right now i think black is doing
well for instance after queen c5 is what
happened in the game
uh but let's whisper happen in the game
let's see what happens after rook d4
uh after rook before queen h4 queen b8
king h7
h6 g7 rook e1
uh position gets totally crazy king b3
just came to hg7
i have no idea who is better here or who
has better chances to
you know be better in the future because
it seems like completely
insane position like both sides have
a very exposed kings is equal material
all both white and black pieces are very
active
to be honest is just a mess it's to me
it's just a mess this position
uh i don't know i don't
anything anything can happen that's for
sure so uh
this doesn't lead to advantage for white
and after queen c5
right now uh jeffrey made the mistake
probably i i guess he was in time
trouble or something
again time pressure and thai rapid time
control in normal time control i
i hopefully have more time and right now
he play rook takes h4 which is a big
mistake
and again in such dynamic opening like
fashnikov you can sort of back out
you have to fully act maximize activity
of all your pieces not only just one or
two
all of them so if you play rookie one
right now
king c2 and queen h4 actually you are
bringing the queen to the game
after okay on the other hand after h4
the queen is still on d8
it's passive right so if the point is
passive that is unlikely that black will
have any good chances of creating
counterattack on white's king
on the other hand after rookie one queen
queens do queen h4
uh black activates all the pieces
including the queen suddenly queen
a4 so just
[Music]
mark it here queen a4 could be an idea i
mean actually is an idea it's just
winning idea if
black was on the move so white has to
react to this
uh for instance queen d4 trying to trade
the queens just queen takes h6 right now
we captured the
the pawn of the queen and uh
[Music]
again it's a completely unclear position
but i don't think black
has any uh reasons to worry here to be
worried here
and of course a g7 loses because of
queen a4
so you can't you you don't have time to
capture the this g7 pawn
so jeffrey play kuruk h4 and again
probably both both west and jeffrey were
in time travel because
i failed to understand why jeffrey white
boys didn't take on g7
i don't see any attack here uh for for
black and seems like it just collects
the pawn and white simply wins uh
king seven for instance just bishop e2
trained to trade one pair of
the bishops it's just extra pawn like
and the white black king is
more exposed actually than white's king
so it
it should be simply winning for black i
analyze for instance rook h1
rook d1 if queen g5 just queen e3
trying to trade simply everything and
retain the extra pawn and simply win the
game
so i think this was simply winning i
guess it was
miss transfer for wesley however his
choice is also very
easy and logical to uh understand from
human point of view
because queen of c8 trades queens
and you want to normally if the position
is so complicated
and you're under attack trading quiz
seems like a reasonable option
it and it in indeed it is what the end
the resulting end game is somewhat
better for it
but it's not like uh it's winning or
something like this
it's not on the other hand this h sorry
h2 g7 just wins the game here on the
spot
i don't see any conversation here for
black whatsoever after quincy
though we entered this uh this end game
rook h6 bishop b7 is probably the royal
wesley's point
and the idea is that the pawn defies the
weakness and
it's easier a little bit easier to push
white spawns and black spawns on the on
the
queen side uh
here it's not anymore about the opening
is more like you know
what you know what they were doing in
this end game
so uh it's not of that much of an
importance for the you know
topic for today which is the opening and
say dynamic play
in uh in svashnikov or sicilian but
anyway i thought this endgame very
instructive
because till the end it was all about
dynamics so let's just let's just have a
look
what happened and what could have
happened here so rook h5
logical defending the pawn and b4
king of eight uh logic very logical key
needs to be activated
and king b2 king also white clothes
activates the king
right now we just play rogue five and i
don't understand this move really i mean
i understand that he wants to defend
this
free bishop because fc4 could be afraid
but
it seems more natural to play move like
king e7 to me
um but yeah but yeah but it's
probably blue k5 is also quite okay uh
k7
i would probably play and don't see any
big problems with that however
you know we have to consider c4 maybe
this is what he didn't like
uh ruger 5 king b3 k7 right now king a4
g5 both sides try to activate the kings
and they push the pawns
and right now wesley played b5 and
this move was basically uh ruining
uh like little chances that white
actually
had here uh to win the game he won the
game eventually because jeffrey made a
mistake
but the best move was here bishop a8
and the idea here is to basically push
the pawn only now
but bishop a is simply inhuman move to
to be played so
i analyze this quite a lot and i'm more
than happy to
show this but i'm i'm a little bit
worried that we'll run out of time and
under this is coming so i will just skip
this for now
um maybe one of the lessons about end
games
in the end game or something i'll talk
about the same game too so um
in the game b5 rook f4 king a5
king d6
right now position is very balanced it
depends you know
uh black i mean black king is pretty
much very close to the kink to the queen
side
and tries to prevent this pawn from
[Music]
b-pawn from queening but
b6 rook c4 happened rook d3
brook c5 and black has enough
black has enough conversation from the
in the form of activity active piece
after active rogue on c5 active bishop
on uh
f3 which can let's say go to e4 or e2
and then basically play rook b5 or
something like this
um jeffrey uh no i mean sorry wesley
didn't want to make a draw
and he play his move his back
with his king back to uh b3 instead of
just repeating of kimber five uh
sorry a king five king b4 and uh draw he
played king before he tried to
play for owen uh after roger f4 he
played smooth c4
and here king c5 was okay still this is
takes the f4 rook to blue before
king c3 and right now
uh jeffrey made a mistake
uh which give practical which gave
practical chances to
to wesley he played move rook takes b6
however the best uh
you know or one of the easiest ways to
make a draw was simply bishop before
because those
white balls are not going anywhere they
are pinned right
and you know if we hit the rook and
maybe play rooks if
oxford is always the idea uh we can
uh simply uh you know create immediate
counter play like that
after d6 for instance uh there is one
very interesting line we should take d3
uh d7 rook d4 bishop d5 takes b7
actually white promotes to the queen but
after a bishop g6 is simply a fortress
there is no way
what could win that rook
hb6 on the other hand gave black product
gave to wesley practical chances and
probably in time trouble
jeffrey made a mistake uh because of the
time through jefferson made later a
mistake lost the game
because after d6 this this it's all
forced you have to take the
use to give the rook for the for the
bishop
right now uh jeffrey played a move f5
which is a losing move
uh because
it right now after five both pawns are
easily
easily attacked by the uh by the
by by white rook instead of
bishop d5 happened probably i would say
it very
cautiously probably would still be a
draw somehow
uh it's very difficult still from
practical point of view but
probably it's still uh there were some
chances to make a draw
at least with my analysis after let's
take a d3 bishop b6
rook d8 bishop f5 king k3
king c4 for instance here i didn't find
any ways to find to to win this with
with black
with white i mean let's say rook g8
g4 uh rookie back to cut the king we
should be six
i don't see a follow up here for a while
let's say king goes forward or something
we just go
sorry uh if king goes forward just king
c3 for instance
just no way to uh i know
the only idea is to kind of like play at
some point rook c7 maybe try to kick
kick this king out but uh if i don't
if i'm out of the opposition it will
never be possible pretty much
so if you i don't see a clear way for
white to win this
because this seems like a fortress with
bishop 0.6 and covering both
f7 and g4 pawns
anyway this was probably still a draw
but
i i'm not i'm not saying this with 100
guarantee
uh how but what i can say is 100
guarantee f5 was a losing move because
after king d3
king e3 g4 this blockade or like this uh
setup sim doesn't hold because white can
surround a five pawn and
eventually uh win it for instance king
of four happened the game king civil f7
and this is how the game ended and one
way or under white would
eventually manage to uh get get there
and uh transform uh to the following
pawn and game pawn ending which is
theoretically obviously winning
so after rook takes a five uh jeffrey
resigned and
wesley sort of one very important game
uh
to win fully deservedly u.s does to the
2020 worst championships
so to sum it up quickly svechnikov is a
very interesting opening obviously
there is lots of going on there's lots
of theory you have to study
however what what is very important uh
in this opening you have
you have to play very dynamic and very
concrete chess and
sometimes one move not the right
direction can just
be terrible for you so there you have to
be very careful and
the uh calculating a lot and calculating
well
so that's all for for this lesson and i
will see you guys soon with
with the next one which will be games of
the week
[Music]
you